avec le break site la date du 31 janvier
2020 sera à jamais gravé dans les
mémoires et sur une pièce de monnaie
le 31 janvier 3 millions de nouvelles
pièces de 50 pence se seront mises en
circulation par la monnaie royale
britannique sur la pièce la date du
divorce
et ce message paix prospérité et amitié
avec toutes les nations
une citation de thomas jefferson
troisième président américain ils se
foutent symbole de l'indépendance de son
pays
il aura fallu quatre tentatives au
parlement à londres pour arriver à
s'entendre sur le grec cite l'automne
dernier on avait même déjà frappé un
million de pièces avec la date 31
octobre
les pièces qu'on a du fonds en raison
d'un nouveau délai en tout 10 millions
de ces pièces édition break sites seront
mises en circulation cette année
[Musique]